we have already worked through some
examples in which X was a random
variable with a given PDF and we
considered the problem of finding the
PDF of Y for the case where Y was the
function X cube or the function of the
form a over X what both of these
examples have in common is that Y is a
monotonic function of X in this case Y
is increasing with X in this case Y was
decreasing with X it turns out that
there is a general formula that gives us
the PDF of y in terms of the PDF of X in
the special case where we're dealing
with a monotonic function so let us
assume that G is a strictly increasing
function and what that means is that if
X is a number smaller than some other
number X Prime the value of G of X is
going to be smaller than the value of G
X Prime so when you increase the
argument of the function the function
increases to keep things simple we will
also assume that the function G is
smooth in particular that it is
differentiable then we have a diagram
such as this one here is x + y is given
by a function of X it's a smooth
function and that function keeps
increasing now because of the
assumptions we have made on G we have an
interesting situation given a value of x
of corresponding value of y will be
determined according to the function G
but we can also go the other way if I
tell you a value of y then you can
specify for me one and only one value of
x that gives rise to this particular Y
so the function G takes us from X's to
Y's but you can also go back the
opposite way from Y's to values of X and
the mapping that takes us from Y is 2x
is this is the inverse of the function G
and we give a name to that inverse
function and we call it H so H of Y is
the value of x that produces a specific
value Y let us now move on with the
program of finding the PDF of Y we will
follow the usual two-step procedure and
the first step is to find the CDF of Y
so we fix some little why and we want to
find the probability that the random
variable Y takes a value in this range
when does this happen for Y to take a
value in this range it must be the case
that X takes a value in this range here
values of X smaller than this particular
number results in values of Y that are
less than or equal to this particular
number so we can rewrite the event of
interest in terms of the random variable
X and write it as follows we need to
have X less than or equal to H of little
Y but this is just the CDF of X
evaluated at H of Y we now carry out the
second step of our program we take
derivatives of both sides and we find
that the PDF of y is equal to the
derivative of the right-hand side the
derivative of the CDF is a PDF and then
the chain rule tells us that we also
need to take the derivative of the term
inside here with respect to its argument
and this is a general formula for the
PDF of a strictly increasing function of
a random variable X how about the case
of a decreasing function so let us
assume that G now is a strictly
decreasing function of X so we might
have a plot for G that looks something
like this what happens in this case we
can start doing a calculation of this
kind
but now how can we rewrite this event
the random variable Y will take a value
less than or equal to this number little
Y when when does this happen when the
value of G of X is less than Y and that
happens for X's in this range so this is
the set of X's for which the value of G
of X is less than or equal to this
particular number Y so the event of
interest in that case is the event that
X is larger than or equal to H of Y
which is 1 minus the probability that X
is less than H of Y because X is a
continuous random variable we can change
this inequality to one that allows the
possibility of equality and so this is 1
minus the CDF of X evaluated at H of Y
now we take the red buttons of both
sides and we find the PDF of Y being
equal to there's a minus sign here then
the derivative of the CDF which is the
PDF and finally the derivative of the
function H now in this case G is a
decreasing function of X so when X goes
down Y goes up when X goes up Y goes
down this means that when Y goes up X
goes down so it means that the inverse
function age is going to be also
monotonically decreasing since it is
decreasing it means that the slope the
derivative of the function a
is going to be either zero or negative
and so minus a negative value gives us
the absolute value of that number so we
can rewrite this by removing this minus
sign here and putting an absolute value
in this place of course in the case
where G is an increasing function when X
goes up Y goes up this means that when Y
goes up X goes up so H in that case
would have been an increasing function
so this number here would have been a
non-negative number and so it would be
the same as the absolute value so using
these absolute values we obtain formulas
that are exactly the same in both cases
of increasing and decreasing functions
and so our final conclusion is that in
either case the PDF of Y is given in
terms of the PDF of x times the
derivative of this inverse function let
us now apply the formula that we have in
our hands for the monotonic case to a
particular example where Y is the square
of X and where X is uniform on the
interval 0 to 1 so the function G in our
case the function G is the square
function now you could argue here that
this function is not monotonic so how
can we apply our results on the other
hand the random variable X takes values
on the interval from 0 to 1 and
therefore the form of the function G
outside that range does not concern us
over the range of values of interest the
function G is a monotonic function so
what is the correspondence Y is going to
be equal to X
that's the G of X function and when that
happens we have the relation that X is
going to be the square root of Y this
tells us that the inverse function H of
Y which tells us what is the particular
X associated with a given Y the inverse
function takes the form square root of Y
so now we can go ahead and use the
formula the density at some particular
little Y where that little y belongs to
the range of values of interest X takes
values between 0 & 1 so Y also takes
values between 0 & 1
so over that range the density of Y is
the density of X which is uniform
therefore it is equal to 1 times the
derivative of the square root function
and the derivative of the square root
function is 1 over 2 times the square
root of Y as you can see the amount of
calculations involved here are rather
simpler compared to what we would have
to do if we were to go through our
two-step program and work with CDF all
that you need to do is essentially to
identify the inverse function that given
a Y produces X's and write down the
corresponding derivative